[Musique]
la vie d'une autre et panneaux est
difficile oui tous les jours c'est un
combat pour la drépanocytose est une
maladie de la douleur plus ou moins
intenses
en tout cas c'est la principale plaintes
des patients à trépas l'hosto c'est une
maladie rare mais c'est une maladie
négligée quelque peu oubliée dans les
pays où justement elle pose un grand
problème de santé publique
la drépanocytose est la maladie
génétique la plus répandue dans le monde
elle touche plusieurs millions de
personnes héréditaire elle est due à une
anomalie de l'hémoglobine l'hémoglobine
malades s'appelle hémoglobine s
les globules rouges prennent la forme de
faucille qui bloquaient des sceaux il
crée douleur aiguë et des complications
parfois mortelles
[Musique]
en guadeloupe 10% de la population est
porteuse du gène de la drépanocytose
une partie d'entre eux souffrent de sa
forme la plus sévère et doit être soigné
régulièrement
evelyne 33 ans habite pointe à pitre
elle a dû apprendre à vivre avec la
maladie dû puy sa naissance
on en face à bet awards dont la façade
n'a pas été heureuse dans ce sens là du
côté de la maladière n'a pas été
heureuse du tout parce que j'étais tout
le temps spitz alizés mais quand je dis
tout le temps c'était tous les mois tous
les images et hospitalisé je ne pouvais
pas aller à l'école comme tous les
enfants je ne pouvais pas faire des
activités sportives comme tous les
enfants
je ne pouvais pas faire des sorties
scolaires comme tous les enfants j'ai
passé mon enfance au chu et si je peux
dire une année 7 365 jours ces douze
mois par an
je passais 10 mois 11 mois au chu je
dois faire de la clinique bouteille
uniquement quand je suis enrhumé et que
je commence à tousser
donc si j'ai commencé à tousser c'est
qu'il ya un dépôt sur les poumons et
pourchasser ceux des poulains je fais de
la kiné goûté on ça évite les infections
thoracique et du grave et les infections
pulmonaires graves
donc je vois tout le temps le conflit va
peut être me stresser non plus je dois
pas me faire me fatiguer non plus je
dois pas me mettre en colère non plus je
ne dois pas me baigner à la mer non plus
je ne vois pas me baigner à la rivière
non plus je dois pas me souffle et je ne
dois pas aller en altitude il ya plein
de choses à faire que je ne vois pas
faire malheureusement